I just got back to my hotel room and my phone
is in need of a charge. What are my options?
Okay, here are three options: one is I take this
USB cable, plug into the slot in the clock radio
and then charge my phone from that. What could
possibly go wrong? I'll tell you what could go
wrong, is that this device could have been
tampered with, and it will now use the data
transfer capabilities of this cable to either
plant malware on my device or take sensitive data
off of it. I don't want to do that! That's known as
a "juice jacking" attack. I could use a specially
made adapter like this that disables the data
transfer and only allows transfer of pure power.
Or the traditional option-- the wall charger right
here into the AC outlet. And I'm probably going
to get a faster charge, I'm going to avoid the
juice jacking scenario, and I'm going to be safer.
After all, you don't know where this thing's been!
Don't just go plugging this in anywhere. Be safe!